my initial thought when with Francis an
Anthony Joshua is this the cat's out of
the bag by the time Fury found that out
he did win a lot of later rounds right
that's why people gave him the fight you
know he got dropped on his ass and then
he was like I didn't get my [__]
together here and started perform a
little better still didn't look great
but it was able to pull it off
technically you're not going to surprise
Anthony Joshua now now Anthony Joshua
has the advantage going that's what he
looks like got it I I need to take this
guy serious or he will you know beat me
got it so this is a much much tougher
fight for Francis andano than Tyson Fury
can he do it absolutely why can he do it
because Anthony Joshua gets hit and when
you're playing the game with Fran andana
who's the hardest hitter this side of
the Congo all it takes is one freaking
hit as Tyson Fury he got dropped on his
ass and that was even a great shot and
this is good if you're a Francis fan but
again cats out of the bag it it's going
to be a much tougher fight for Francis
I'll say that